I've been exploring recently on stage
like [ __ ] I've been talking through
and I think it's the same thing because
I'm not like great at them I've never
been like wow you're the best at this
and and I've never been a girl who's
like I love giving [ __ ] and I've
always heard girls like there are some
girls that say that like I love sucking
dick and I've always been like do they
say that to you or this heads of guys
they say it just just out there and I've
always called [ __ ] on it because I
just think it's like you're just serving
a guy and you there's a way that you can
enjoy it like it's not that comfortable
of a thing but maybe you get some what's
the the compersion where you enjoy
someone else's yes so maybe it's that
but now I realize that the difference
between me and those girls is that those
girls the first time they gave a [ __ ]
I guarantee or one of the first times
the guy was like you're amazing at this
you're really good at this because when
a girl is told or anyone is told early
on the first time they do something that
like you've you have a natural talent at
this you go i I do and then you do it
again and again because you're like I'm
good at this this is my thing and then
you get good at it and you're like it's
my thing but no one ever said that to me
about [ __ ] early on it was always
just kind of like a means to an end and
I feel like if someone would have just
been like lied to me so I am I ask guys
now like just lie to every girl if you
get a [ __ ] and it's like mediocre
just be like you're the best at this
ever like this is the best [ __ ] I've
ever received because she will be so
it'll make her feel good what's gonna
hurt that she thinks she's the best at
this thing that she's not that great at
but she'll do it a lot because she'll be
like I'm great at this and this guy
thinks I'm the greatest at it so she'll
do it a lot and then by doing a lot
she'll get better and then everyone wins
yeah maybe or she could just suck a lot
of dicks and people will lie to her and
then her self-esteem gets shattered if
she runs into the one dude and said who
the [ __ ] told you you're good at this
told me I was great no no I'm not good
at this at all it's all teeth and you're
choking this is crazy but maybe maybe
even a girl that is really good at them
can meet a guy that's like you're
terribly because everyone likes
different styles so I think that you run
that risk
regardless maybe some guys just like
really bad [ __ ] right like some guys
like [ __ ] from someone who seems
like they've never done it before that
way they don't feel like they're the
ninetieth in line oh that's a really
good point Joe like you could be into a
[ __ ] that's kind of apprehensive and
like what am i doing because like a
virginal type situation yeah just
putting on an act it's got pigtails on I
just schoolgirl outfit what am i doing
wait what do you teach what do you do
with this you sure oh my god my friend
recently cuz we've talked a lot of me my
friend I've talked a lot about how we
just are insecure that we're bad at
[ __ ] and we've taken classes at
Babeland or they think about classes oh
yeah a [ __ ] who's teaching the
classes girls are guys I think it was
like a gay guy and a woman together gay
guy I was thinking gay guys should know
how to suck it there cuz he has one I've
read everything I've watched tutorials I
just it's just not getting through to me
I just I haven't I tried and I'm not
like bad at them like I don't think I'm
bad at them but I just I think I always
was apprehensive because I think the
first thing I heard about [ __ ] was
that the first complaint I would hear
around me was too much teeth and I've
always had like really big teeth and
some like smile I have big teeth this is
sound like did not abnormal but I was
just like I had buck teeth as a kid so I
was people always called me like a
beaver I was like that my teeth are
gonna get in the in the way of this so I
immediately that was my biggest issue
and then you learned that like that's
easy to like work around and then so
anyway but my friend said that she
learned this new trick when she's
hooking up she'll do a role play of like
will you teach me how to do a blow job
but she's actually like wanting them to
teach her and so it's a hot thing where
like she gets to role play but she
honestly doesn't know and gets and then
the guy tells her exactly what to do and
then if she messes up it's like part of
the character as opposed to her being
bad at blow jobs so that's my next thing
I'm gonna try and think so you the guys
invested in the project yeah and if you
mess up your own you're just that's part
of your character you're just being good
at the roleplay yeah it's not because
you're innately bad but then when you
break up you like listen [ __ ] I
sucked a 100 dick before you I know
what I was doing I was trying to make
you feel better you [ __ ] loser by the
way they were all bigger than yours all
of us exactly